I'm Jeremy Brock
welcome to the BAFTA and BFI
international screenwriters lecture
series for 2013 I was on the BAFTA Film
committee and discovered I was the only
screenwriter who'd ever been on it and
after I got over the shock I decided
that the best I could do for my
screenwriting brothers and sisters was
to set up a lecture series in the name
of BAFTA and we were able to bring the
BFI in on that this year we've got a
fantastic lineup we start with David s
Goyer we end with Richard Curtis and in
between we have Hossein Amini Susannah
grant and Tony Gilroy these are serious
heavyweights from the UK and from
America you will be inspired by these
individuals we have been trying to get
Richard Curtis since day one of day one
so this is a huge pleasure because I had
begun to give up hope that we would ever
manage to lure Richard in if you ask
someone in the street to name a famous
screenwriter they probably couldn't but
they might come up with Richard Curtis
that's how famous is and if you look at
his filmography you're looking at the
list not a list the list of the
best-selling British films of all time
he's almost created a genre of his own
and has written a mirror that holds
itself up to us as British people one of
the keys to the success of the series is
that we don't give up on those we love
and even though they come up with very
very good excuses we just don't accept
that so it's a particular pleasure to
have Richard Curtis closing the series
because tonight we have some serious
heavyweight writers in the audience and
I am really looking forward to hearing
what he has to say
this is almost my first lecture all the
other lectures I've ever given have been
to my children
and I'm still doing the washing-up so
I'm not exactly convinced of the
efficacy of the lecture form and also I
do also want to say that everything that
I say will only be partially true or as
it were only true for me
which is a really important thing I'm a
screenwriters on the whole don't talk to
each other about what they do for
instance I've always think it's a clever
thing to leave myself notes for the next
day so I've never woken up and started
writing with an empty page in front of
me there may be other people for whom
the empty page is absolutely key without
it they couldn't as it were feel the
challenge I write enormous amounts I
write 20 30 pages of stuff a day and
hope that some of its good there may be
other people who do the exact opposite
who care about every word and don't put
it down until they're sure it's right so
I seriously don't know what's right or
wrong and all I can do is tell you
what's true for me and the first bit now
is going to be of the evening I've
decided to use my inspiration Jeremy
Paxman and because I'm just going to ask
myself the same question a few times and
try and give a few different answers
and the question is is why I'll be
answering that and then I think Edith
and I have agreed that we might talk
about how as it were about the process
is a little bit more and then you can
ask what ever you like the first
question I've asked myself is why did I
start writing films and the answer is
because someone called Michael an
American asked me to write a film so I
got a phone call from my agent saying he
wants to see you tonight and I thought
of the idea for the film that I was
going to sell him on the Northern Line
and that was the first big mistake that
I've never made again which is that I
always have lived with the idea of any
film that I'm going to do for at least a
year before I eventually start writing
it films can't be infatuations they've
got to be relationships and I suppose
this is my first observation that I
think the difference between having a
good idea for a film and a finished film
that you like is the same as seeing a
pretty girl at a party and being there
when your wife delivers the third baby
it's an incredibly long journey and a
good idea is is only a is only the tiny
little spark at the beginning of this
immense process pretty when I came up
with the idea for Michael it was about a
father and a son who both found out on
their on the same night that the girls
they were with the girlfriend and the
wife were having sex with other people
and so they both as it were left their
flat and their house and moved in
together in a hotel and had to as it
were deal with their peculiar situations
together and it was called four eyes and
fat thighs and I think that's the only
thing I really got out of excites
weirdly close to four weddings and a
funeral so it was their first and then I
wrote a draft I went out to LA and I
wrote a second draft under the producers
eagle-eye in his guest room and then he
put me together with a direct
with whom I wrote a third draft and then
we handed it in and we had what I think
is quite a typical American meeting they
loved the script
they really loved it and I asked them
did they have any reservations at all
because their smiles were so big and
they said the dialogue wasn't great it
was it was too English and a bit too
formal and I said all right and then
they said that the two leading
characters were not good because they
were both weak and they need you needed
someone to be able to root for in the
movie and then they said and obviously
the jokes are all very English so we'd
have to think of jokes that would appeal
more to an American sense of humor and I
remember saying to them that really only
leaves the title and they said we hate
the title but the strange thing was they
still said can't wait to get the next
draft so I went home I was staying with
a friend of mine by this stage because I
was sort of having a nervous breakdown
I got a self-induced temperature of 103
about a week later I flew home to
England metro-goldwyn-mayer sued me in
perpetuity I never delivered the script
and that explains pretty well everything
about what I have done since then first
never do a project that you haven't
thought about beforehand be sure that
you're working with people who actually
like the work you do which i think is
hugely important choose the people you
work with really carefully this director
was a lovely man but I remember when we
were talking about the film the very
first day he said oh I so identify with
this film when my wife left me I just
went out and had sex with a different
girl every night for a month and this
was a film about two men who'd only ever
had sex with one person in their entire
lives so he was completely and utterly
the wrong man to be making this film but
most importantly and this isn't a rule
for everyone but it sort of is explains
everything since then
I decided that I would never write a
film about anything that I didn't really
know about very personally I didn't know
I realized when I was right in the film
where Americans shopped I didn't know
what they'd watched on TV when they were
kids I didn't know anything about the
structure of their schools so I came
straight home and I wrote a film called
Camden town boy which was eventually
called the tall guy about someone who
lived in Camden town where I lived about
someone who had hay fever which I had
and about someone whose job was to be a
straight man to a comedian whose name
was in the script Ron Anderson and my
job was to be Rowan's straight Rowan
Atkinson's straight man so I have always
since then basically stuck to what I
think is true to my experience and
emotionally right for me so that's why I
started on a career of small personal
English films and was absolutely key and
I think the other thing that was key in
the development of myself as a
screenwriter was one sentence in William
Goldman's fabulous book called
adventures in the screen trade which I
would recommend anyone who hasn't read
to read where he said that most
directors end up making films that
vaguely remind them of a screenplay that
they once read and it's that it's that
that that sentence is the stake of fear
through my heart that's dominated
everything I've done since then the next
question I've asked myself is why so
many of the films or the films have
generally turned out as I hoped they
would and this is quite a complicated
and odd thing and I didn't realise as it
was going to be the core of what I was
going to say when I was asked about it I
thought well I'll write about playing
lots of pop music while I'm writing but
on the whole the films that I've worked
on have turned out
I intended and I don't know how
replicable it is and I don't know if my
experience is very personal but I would
say that from my point of view a huge
amount of the challenge facing a
screenwriter is about control and that
is a very important tricky area when it
came to for weddings I decided I was
going to take it even more seriously we
made a deal that we me and Duncan would
be involved in every part of the process
of making the film which meant being
there when it was being cast being there
every day when it was shot and being
there a lot of the time when it was
being edited even though not all the
time and so strangely for me in the end
I decided simply in order to stay alive
that I would take to directing myself
which obviously comes with pluses and
minuses I am probably the worst director
that I've worked with but at least I
know what I want and and how it should
be and that it will be accurate what
you've got to be very careful I'm
particularly aware of the of how
horrible it is to have a stubborn writer
in the Edit and I hope that I'm more
ruthless in editing my own films then
then anyone else could possibly be
certainly that's been my experience I'm
always saying take out more but I do
feel that you should as a writer if you
can try to be there when it's done
because you don't want to waste your
life making or having other people make
the wrong films and now that the final
bit which is the most surprising bit to
me of all and I've only it's in a seem
odd to you but I only started to think
about it four days ago is why I have
actually written the films that I've
written at all I suddenly thought why
have I written this bunch of films
instead of another bunch of films I've
said here when I thought of first
writing movies
these were my favorite 10 films
Godfather 1 Godfather 2 The Adventures
of Robin Hood dog day afternoon Immanuel
1 Emmanuel 2 white Christmas Close
Encounters of the Third Kind Animal
House and a streetcar named desire and
it never even occurred to me that I
could write anything like any of those
films in the same way that often you end
up marrying someone who's not the
slightest bit like you but there was
another bunch of films which for some
reason or other I felt I could identify
with and could do something like and I'm
interested in why why I thought that why
I didn't think I could do the other type
and there's strange thing to me is that
I wrote my first film when I was 30 and
I really ended up the key things that
I've written have been on the same
subjects about they've been about love
and they've been about friendship and
they've been about family and thinking
about tonight I've been as puzzled as
some of the people who are very critical
of my films are why I would bother doing
it again and again and again and I've
tried to think about this why why why
have I not gone down a lot of other
routes and I've taken a bit of
consolation I've got a second slide here
from thinking about artists and I'm not
comparing myself with these but I don't
know if you've got sugar didn't eat in
ever there are lots of cities and lots
of you know cafeterias and lots of soup
cans but every time he sat down he
thought oh I know I'll make everything a
bit blue and and put some flowers in it
and on the whole people would be jumping
over houses
and then if we just go on and look at
the other two oh there we go
must have led a life of great variety
but every time he put pen to paper these
people and then they're just the last
one there we go
really ah all you thought he must have
been able to see there were other ways
of going about things but for some
reason or other and I do think that
there is a thing about style you know as
it were brush to paper and pen to paper
which is the thing that you do and
there's probably not much that you can
do about that and so I I've just been
thinking that it must be the reason I've
written all these films is because the
things that I feel most deeply must be
about those subjects in my own life so I
was raised in a family that was full of
love that's what was the big thing in my
youth was as it were-- family love and
all the big emotions and all the big
things that I felt been in this area in
the area of romantic love family love
friendship and not as it were in the
area of serial killers superheroes
people who died 300 years ago secrets
scandals corruption action sporting
victories gangsters things from outer
space all of these things that are a few
Djinn turists to other people and take
up their time would clearly not been the
thing which inspired me I've just
written in a lot of times about about
love friends and family because it would
seem that if you really write what you
care about you as it were have no choice
and that must be why I've rarely written
about anything else and maybe that takes
me back to the beginning all the
mistakes I made on the first film I
found that what I do best is when I
write what is true to me well I
understand and
hope that I have listened in more ways
than one to my own instincts in my own
heart and at least for the moment that's
my expectation explanation why I've
ended up writing the things that I have
are you ready to react wish control
slightly yes good glad to hear that
you've got all the clips I told you that
we must have really think so they're
already littered with big red button up
there yeah we ready we're good and
before we get to the clips though and
we've got to start with the question on
how how are you approach writing a
screenplay I mean just very quickly on
that I've been trying to think how do I
write a screenplay because I certainly
don't sit down in a month or two months
I think the answer is I think of an idea
ages before and then I kind of write a
long weird prose poem to myself with
lots of bits of dialogue in it which is
just a discussion so I say this might
happen in the middle of these might be
the characters this might be the end
this might be the beginning I mean I
would never write a treatment by the way
I think they are shockingly bad idea
I genuinely think that a treatment is
the equivalent of a prose description of
a painting I think I will draw a picture
of a pretty woman with a landscape
behind her and you're not quite sure
whether she's smiling or sad
that's the Mona Lisa but I genuinely
think they're and their nonsense so I
would have never done I've never done
that if I can and and then slowly a kind
of then I think I'd write down on cards
incidents that are in it and see whether
or not suddenly I've got a hundred
things that start to be in a order
that's vaguely sensible and then I will
start having a go at writing I find it
really fascinating when you were talking
in your lecture about how how involved
you are it I mean is that quite a unique
thing for a writer who's not the
director of the film to be that involved
through that whole process I think it is
but
you know we've made it work and it's
been complicated I mean I I think I
really do think of my job as a
screenwriter being pretty well equal in
the I mean actually obviously if you're
then directing the movie that bit sequel
my contribution to the motive the
directing of the movie was was you know
not as importantly what I think is very
important to be there but I think the
editing of films again I it really is a
massive rewrite and it is a
extraordinarily important part of the
process and I can't if I could take you
guys through time to see how disastrous
at least four of the films that I've
been involved in have been when they
were thought to be finished it is I mean
Bridget Jones was catastrophic yeah
and with the movie we shot even though
every single frame of it was then in the
finished movie it was not the right
movie we just got all sorts of things
wrong in the screenplay like there were
two laughs in it in the whole film and
it was there some of you who may have
seriously and think that well that's
more than I remember but but in front of
a crowd it used to get some laughs and
we just we were getting completely the
wrong reaction to the film and then
suddenly one day we realized that the
problem was that Bridget as presented on
film was a pretty girl in a good job who
both Hugh Grant and Colin Firth wanted
to sleep with and it was not a
challenging scenario or one where
somebody deserved a much sympathy or
interest and so what we did quite near
the end is we took the saddest scene in
the film which was right at the end when
she'd been dumped for the third time by
I mr. Darcy or I can't remember where it
was but it was the last 5 minutes or 10
minutes of the movie and we made it the
credit sequence of the film so I think
it might be interesting to look at the
credits of Brigitte and see that the
reason why people then were sympathetic
and liked the film I mean we did then
cut 15 out of the next 30 minutes to try
and speed it up and stuff but the
credits of the film this was the
emotional climax and end of the film
until as it where she ran through snow
the strange thing is that is to her
emotion is too big for a opening credits
sequence I think that you can see how
that would have been quite near the end
of the movie with her in real trouble
and really really sad and everything but
by moving that up we changed the fate of
there I think most women watching that
we go god did that movie but a month ago
the characters almost have you know you
associate characters with certain pieces
of music then as well whilst you're
right in its achill that does it go that
far
I don't know that it's characters so
much as emotional moods yeah and talk of
emotional moods if you want to get to a
point with something do you feel like
with film and with screen right and you
need to find a a journey to get there as
opposed to just seeing things as they
are because you've got a great example
of you just from from nothing how of
this the scene with Julia okay yeah I've
got I've actually got my pocket my hid
my hints if we've got time
we're private I might just tell you as
it were things the tricks that I use
which I'm sure will not be useful to
most of you but interesting I mean I'll
just be honest one of the things that
I've found in most of my films there was
a bit torn between an example I could
have given you from almost every film
that sometimes when I'm stuck on a film
completely and trying to work out what
to do and feeling that I haven't got
there I and this will unfortunately
destroy the scene that everyone's about
to see but I just write exactly what the
film is
about in what people say it's so often
and I think it's a bit of a British
tradition I actually won't
I won't quite ever say well I'll let
people maybe imply vaguely what the
emotional journey was meant to be and
I'm quite a believer in in going
straight for it so I mean this is a this
is a you know key scene and Notting Hill
but if you listen to it again again
you're just you're a discriminating
audience you probably thought the first
time you saw it
wow this is exactly him saying what the
film is about but this was me writing
straight at Notting Hill to try and say
what I thought the film was about I live
in Notting Hill you live in Beverly
Hills everyone in the world knows who
you are
my mother has trouble remembering my
name
fine good decision good decision
the fame thing isn't really real you
know and don't forget I'm also just a
girl standing in front of a boy asking
him to love her so well I just say
there's that was a piece of piece of
work you know a very deliberate thing to
try to exactly sum up what I thought the
whole film was is about how do you know
when something's funny that's quite
interesting I you do you do laughs when
you write something funny I mean and
that is really interesting because when
we wrote Blackadder
I used to notice that because back ed it
was quite you know constructional you
you know you kind of knew what people
would do and how the plot would go and
you could make things funny in a way and
there were quite a lot of things we did
repetitively and whenever I actually
laughed I would underline things so I
would remember that actually made me
laugh rather than something that I
worked towards and at the end of the
whole process Ben said what were those
funny lines that used to be underneath
the script so he'd obviously never
noticed they were the funniest lines I'd
ever written
okay questions from our audience you
mentioned your own family background and
whereas most family backgrounds as I
mentioned are bad memories for the
person telling you about them you refer
to a close and loving family background
my question is if you had not had that
kind of family
ground does it mean that you simply
would not have become a screenwriter or
would you do you think have written
films with influence from the kind of
awful background you'd had becoming a
parent I realize in retrospect I'm very
interested in things going well I think
there is a it's real it would be
interesting to talk with people who
disagree because I find things going
well very very interesting and I know
that there are lots of people who when
they see a situation look for the thing
that's wrong and say that's the truth
I mean I have said before that I'm
sometimes puzzled by the fact that when
I write films about people falling in
love they are critically taken to be
sentimental and unrealistic and yet four
million people in London are in love
tonight and today all around the world
hundreds of thousands of people will
fall in love when someone writes a film
about a soldier going AWOL and breaking
into a flat and murdering a young
pregnant woman something which has
happened twice in history that film will
be described as searingly realistic I
don't see how that's true I was on a
beach in South world the other day and
you look alone you see fathers playing
with their children people in love
holding hands older couples having cups
of tea with each other no sign
whatsoever of ruthless violence and
hatred on that Beach now of course I
know from my work with comic relief
about the dark art of the UK but that's
not the only that's not the only story
and I think stories of joy and love are
definitely worth worth telling and I'm a
beneficiary of that and long may you
tell them
yeah before we let you go till we have
your tricks of the trade oh gotta have
these alright so I did just write them
down these are absurd I I cannot believe
I'm gonna say this in front of
mathematics at the ready I can't believe
I was saying this in front of
Christopher Hampton I I live in a street
with only two houses in the street and
I'm the second best writer and the third
best director as my as my son Charlie
now knows more about what have I written
here I can say that I've said the thing
about going on the nose oh this is just
a hint of mine which I do think is
helpful if you're a writer is when I get
stuck which is often I always write 1 2
3 4 5 in the gap on the page and then I
give myself five goes at the problem so
I don't have that dreadful pressure of
thinking I gotta get it right this time
what is he going to say to her what can
they do I just write something that's
the same as the thing I wrote before
something that's a bit different
something that's completely different
something with another character and
something from outer space is the web
and by the time you've relaxed enough to
write the 5 you often find that
somewhere in the 5 is the answer that
you need whereas the pressure of having
to get it right I find very hard to get
writer's block often no I mean I get
completely stuck and that's when I stop
typing and sit down with a pad and write
in pencil so I can't see what I'm doing
this is bad thing to reveal but I do I
have to admit that I do sometimes at
certain points right as I say like a
mixing desk I've got to a certain point
and I can see it's all a bit fuzzy and
so I say if you've ever been in a studio
when they're making a record it's so
annoying because they turn up the sax
and then they fiddle with a sax for two
hours and you say oh god this is all
going to be sax the whole thing and then
they fix the sax and then they pull it
down and it rejoins the track and I do
have some days where I just say I've
just got to do plot
I'm sure there's something wrong so I
just do plot and then the next day I've
taped down the plot and lift up the
character and I get characters who I
don't think are talking to each other
convincingly and they talk to each other
all day and then when I fixed that I
reintroduce that and then I'll do jokes
another day I say it just isn't funny
enough and I'm going to go through it
all and try and do that so that's
another as it were workmen like trick
that I do
never leave a blank page in the morning
this is the most important one of all
don't call your boys by girls names and
your girls by boys names it's so
annoying when you read a script and the
husband's called Carol and the wives
called Alex and the whole way through
the film you can't remember who why and
then some reason or other alex is giving
birth to somebody and stuff so you can
change the window when the actors have
faces you can call them whatever you
like but in a script call them by names
that are identifiably of the right of
the right sex this was a car just to say
if you're if anybody ever talks to you
about the death of romantic comedy I
think that should be ignored because I
think good romantic comedies are funny
films about love and I would say in this
decade we've had lost in translation 500
days of summer Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind these are great great
films about love probably better than in
the ten years before they were the 10
years before that so I think it's just a
question in terms of movies about love
of rephrasing it and not not just going
by eye you know a formula yeah and then
the most important one of all oh no
here's one not very important one which
is if you're a writing comedy and you
want to make something funnier that way
to do it is go to where it's already
funny and make it a bit funnier than
that
so in Notting Hill there's a scene where
Hugh goes in and he's pretending he's
from Horse and Hound and he interviewed
Julia and when Tim Bevan gave me his
note that he's given on every single
film I've ever written which is not very
funny is it
then I went to that bit and I thought
okay so he comes out and look I knew
that bit was funny and I thought how can
I extend that bit rather than finding
another bit where I had to make it all
funny so I thought what would happen if
we came around the corridor and then was
said now you can talk to everybody else
so that's just a little practical comedy
hint and then this is the last one I've
written where I say love yourself
99% failure is a triumph and I often do
think that I think when I'm talking to
people who are writing and they if I
write and there's one good bit that is
an extraordinary day and I will think
I'll end it and I'll think I really got
that bit and wouldn't it be more I can
see that being in the final film and I
know that many young writers they write
and they say oh it's all [ __ ] and then
they say I mean there was one bit there
might be okay but the whole day was
dreadful and you've got to just reverse
that and see that if you produce
anything that's of worth in terms of the
life of writing a film because films are
quite quick to write because they just
dialogue you could type out a film in
three days you couldn't type out a novel
in three days but you should you know be
proud of hopeful of observant for
anything that's anything that's good
Richard thank you so much for tonight
okay
you